A brief introduction Brothers,
First the beauty of Hebrews is recognized by theologians through all the ages,
Hebrews is seen as the most eloquent book of the New Testament without a doubt,
The most eloquent book and speaking from a doctrinal point of view one of the most Important.
4 Who is the Author
Who is the author of the book?
We do not know, but we know for sure many things: first, that the book was already being quoted as scripture in the early church
And in many sectors of the early church in the whole world, known at that time,
Before the year 95 AD.
This means that one of the fathers of the church wrote the book, one of the fathers of the church,
Now the early church itself did not agree among them self who wrote the book.
Different sectors of the church attributed the book or them Attributed the book to different authors.
A great sector thought that Paul wrote the book,
Another sector thought that Barnabas wrote it, another part of the curch thought that Apollos wrote it,
Now one thing is true, if the Lord had wanted us to know, he would have told us,
It is the only book that besides 1st John whose author is unknown in the New Testament,
In the New Testament the only book besides 1st John whose author is not known for sure,
Of course we know who is the author of 1st John but not Hebrews.
Why shall we dedicate  precious time to speech on the evidence that it was Paul, evidence that it was Apollos, evidence that it was Barnabas, and conclude nothing,
We could  spend literally a whole morning giving evidence of who the author could be and what?
And miss the beauties that are in this book, because this book deserves weeks, eternity to understand it,
But definitely, we will not spend more time talking by the author.